good evening hello everybody thank you
very much I kept the glasses on very
vain but I've kept on because I want to
get this right I I want to just start by
quickly saying I want to thank you all
personally I love each and every one of
you for joining us tonight and making it
such a special evening just to be
serious for a moment as you can imagine
we had some quite sobering conversations
about feeling a bit weird about having a
big party this week that we came to the
conclusion that spending a night in
London this beautiful city celebrating
brilliant strong talented wonderful
trailblazing women is an absolutely
appropriate response to those who would
change the way we live so I wanted to do
that and I really can't thank you enough
for all agreeing with us about that and
being here tonight so shall we just get
on with there's another another total
batter I love this woman as a child she
was taunted about the way she looked
and now those looks are the thing that
has made her one of the world's most
sought-after supermodels and I mean if
that's not the inspiring story and what
is the camera eat her up whether she's
the star of an ad campaign for a
beautiful luxury brand or serving up
some attitude and a Beyonce video all
eyes are on her you cannot take your
eyes off her discovered on Instagram
very like in a modern way she's helped
spark a huge shift in our cultural
definitions of beauty and she uses that
platform to bring others with her
through her being such a fierce advocate
for body positivity and diversity and
she did that with absolute charm and
grace and poise at the glamour beauty
festival earlier this year the audience
is captivated
she told us recently that one of her
goals for this year was to win an award
and I am thrilled to be the one to
distill it on her
and to have her as one of our amazing
women of the year covers for the issue
that you will get when you leave tonight
the glamour editors award is for the
amazing Winnie Harlow super super
nervous
I hate week incredible thank you so much
Joe
I forgot that I did say that I was one
of my goals this year guys oh my gosh
I'm winning award that was one of my
goals I always write down my goals every
year and this is one of them and I'm
happy I shared that with you because I
have a little something that I literally
just wrote so don't touch me
but I'm going to end it with a little
bit of a story super short quote I just
want to say thank you guys so much for
having me
glamour thank you so much Joe oh my god
my heart's beating so fast I'm honored
I'm grateful I'm blessed I am I'm so
humbled to be here and to be accepting
that support that is iconic God chose me
to be great and to shine just like
everyone else but it's really about
owning that and accepting that within
yourself I'm sure you've heard a lot
about my story but it's not all she was
bullied and now she's a model there were
so many things in between that I was
raised by a very strong single mother I
had you know siblings yes for my mom
right I had siblings that you know were
incarcerated that I was will be looking
up to and I was the one who was supposed
to be strong all of a sudden so you know
my life has not always been about my
skin I know the media focus focus is so
much about it but I'm so much more than
that
and I'm so blessed to now be living here
in London I live here now this was crazy
I've been living here for almost a year
now and I'm so happy that you guys have
accepted me with a warm welcome and
speaking of being out here and living my
dreams I have my best friend who I
brought out here from Toronto for this
award tonight
my name is Shannon Hamilton she's a 6
foot gorgeous goddess who needs to be
modeling and accepting awards just like
me actually a year ago July 1st which is
coming around she was last year she was
shot in both legs one in her thigh and
one of her ankle and today she's walking
and I'm so happy I'm so blessed she
still has my best friend here with me
and I want her to live her dream the
same way that I'm living walking so I'm
so grateful that she's so here with us
today and she can company and see me
with my dreams and I hope I can inspire
you Shannon to go out and live your
[Applause]